my kid
they'll come and say stuff to me right
and let's just say I try to use a parent
card a father card and I'm being lazy
about being a father and I'm just kind
of using my power and then they come
back and they corn on me the reason you
know what happens I get upset but
they're right all right so now I'm kind
of sitting there saying freaking Tico
okay Tico let's reason and then I'll
reason I'm like I got it I gotta give
this guy this one he won this one I'm
not going to tell him he won it but you
won this one here you go t go ahead and
do this right these people who've been
bullshitting people have to eventually
reason or eyeballs go away we watched
the news for one reason we want you to
show us a way that we're not thinking
give us perspective and then for us to
say okay cool I got you I want to tune
in let me ask you this question what is
the reasoning what is the mentality
behind people at the top trying to
interfere with a parent and their child
in their upbringing in their sexuality
in their morality what do they think
they can gain what
there's got to be some ulterior motive
some big picture that they think they're
going to create behind this it's absurd
to think that you can get in between a
parent and a child with respect to their
education their sexuality their morality
so what is the big picture thought that
they have behind this because these are
the things that I can either be so
cynical and and and come up with
something or I just can't figure it out
I was at a Wayne Hughes event at his
house in Malibu and they brought Dennis
Prager there to speak and he said here's
what the left is doing the left is
trying to make animals and human beings
equal
men and women equal gays and straights
equal okay God and human equal parents
and kids equal employer and employee
equal the risk taker and you know every
they're trying to make everything equal
right because they crippled the person
that's the Doer
they crippled the father and the mother
that are paying the bills and funding
the house they crippled a man that
brings the security when has your woman
ever brought you security but so is that
so that they can become more dependent
upon them no because it's the ultimate
uh Machiavelli divide and conquer okay
yeah I'm saying but what's the what's
the reason behind it you said it
machiavelle because they want everybody
to be dependent upon them
no because the moment you are able to
create a division between two people now
you can turn the other person into
villain and you can win the other victim
over you can't ever recruit a doer
Michael the hardest people to recruit
are doers
because doers don't need you let me say
this one more time the hardest people to
recruit
are doers who are responsible who get up
and work who pay their bills who are
doing everything right who have their
own Ambitions their own dreams their own
Vision on the life they want to build
you can't just recruit them with the
victimhood mentality stuff you can't
okay they know that they're not as equal
as somebody ahead of them they know that
they understand that game but the victim
the other guys they're very easy to
recruit okay where you're talking about
a child
you know a five or six or seven year old
child
I mean they're right where they want to
be able to to give them vaccine without
the permission of their parents
what kind of gall do they have do they
think that they can pull something like
this off you're a parent yeah what would
you do if somebody said hey I'll
vaccinate your kids I don't need your
permission and they try to alienate your
child from you
I mean this is this is something that
would get people incensed and it's
happening I mean parents are going crazy
over this what's the what's the thought
behind that it's the same thing they
want to take control over them you know
they want to divide and conquer exactly
so that they so that everybody becomes
dependent upon them yeah I mean this has
been going on for for a very very long
time this has been going on for a very
very long time you know you go around
American Gangster the scene Denzel is
standing there what are they giving away
in the city turkeys why are they giving
that away hey if we give away turkeys
you'll be quiet about the fact that I'm
selling Blue Magic in the streets right
okay hey these guys are good guys I
don't know what you're talking about hey
go to Medellin I was in uh Bahamas last
week and you go to Carlos Leader's plane
where he crashed and I went snorkeling
there right great experience and that
was the airport
Nelson what's it called uh anyway
something k no this is okay Nelson's K I
think it's Nelson maybe it's a different
word no it's a different word I believe
anyways where they would and then
eventually they had too much cocaine and
they crashed it right okay go to medaine
and ask people about Pablo look how many
people will say how much they love them
yeah
look how many people be offended how
could you say something like that he was
a very good man why was he a good man
because he he won votes through giving
things away for free same with right oh
no didn't he not do that yeah yeah but
but here's the thing this is this is our
our teachers union okay that has the
support of the government this is the
government trying to divide a parent and
a child
this is totally you just made my point
it's totally Machiavelli that's what's
going on here and what's the ulterior
motive it's control yeah so that's what
we're dealing with that's why I wrote
the book Patrick and this is what people
have to understand there's more of a of
a game plan here from these people
on the top and we have to you know as a
republic we have to fight against this
we can't allow this to happen people
parents are up in an uproar and they
should be they shouldn't tolerate this
kind of stuff from I mean who are these
people we elect them and put them in
office they're you know we lost sight of
things look I spoke to the Senate staff
on uh the anniversary of 9 11 at one
point in time and they took me on a tour
through everything I'm sure you've done
that before
people don't want to give any of that up
I mean they don't even go out in the
rain you know they get you know tunnels
with things that they drive so don't
have to get wet they don't want to give
it up that's all there's they don't care
they don't want to give it up I believe
in term limits let them have to you
throw them the heck out after that let
them go get a job if they want to come
back you know four years later whatever
but throw them the heck out you cannot
give people power for that long because
then it all it's all about keeping
control and power and that's what's
Happening Here hegelian dialectic has
been around for a long time okay create
a problem blame him coming as the hero
it's a very basic format on what they're
using right create the problem fabricate
it you're the one that fabricates it the
politicians right then come out and say
I cannot believe Kai
created this problem with these searches
never show up on time it always goes to
the different website it's Kai's fault
right and then come out and say but for
only 9.99 I have the solution okay and
we can sell this software but we have to
replace Kai but I created the problem
right they've been doing this for a long
time the challenge becomes when the
American people are naive to it and when
you're naive to it and you pay a price I
hate to say this to you but you deserved
it because you were blind you were not
willing to be studying on what's going
on in the marketplace and why they're
doing this they're going to win over a
lot of people Michael they're going to
win over a lot of people until they wake
up went and visited my mom we were
having lunch together she was making me
piroshki which if you haven't had to die
for she's a great cook but I said it
said so where you at politics I said
this I'm I'm no longer I'm no longer
following this stuff I know because she
was a full-on card carrying communist
I'm no longer there you kidding me I'm
seeing what some of these guys are doing
they've lost their minds but you know it
took her
70 some years to be at that point so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]